can everyone hear me okay cool
hi I'm Amy well bellow I go by cellular
Hg on the Internet
I'm a programmer and electrical engineer
by trade with an interest in combining
computing an art and an interest in
making STEM education more inclusive and
accessible after working as a web
developer for several years a couple
years ago I founded my own company
called bubble sort genes to try to write
learning materials to make computer
science concept more inclusive and
accessible with stories and
illustrations and in that vein this
presentation is going to use
illustrations to help prove the
algorithm to calculate the phase of the
Moon so let me set the scene for you it
was midnight and the which side in her
tower boom as midnight as the moonlight
danced through the window she was deep
in thought and calculation these runes
were giving her trouble but she felt
confident that she could solve them and
with them the secrets of the moon with a
few more tries the runes keeping her
awake and keeping her from the secrets
of the moon weren't Egyptian hieroglyphs
nor ancient etruscan they were
trigonometry if you two have been
frustrated or terrified by trigonometry
fret not would it be as satisfying to
unlock the secrets of the universe if it
were straightforward it might be
challenging but we can do it right now
here together let's use trigonometry to
calculate the phases of the Moon so a
couple months ago I found this
JavaScript library that makes
astronomical calculations including this
function for calculating what fraction
of the moon is illuminated on any given
day
my first thought to myself was whoa this
library is rad my second thought was can
I prove this equation from first
principle and when I say first
principles I mean very first principles
let's start off with a very basic
question what even is a moon phase
depending on the day
sometimes we see the moon as a crust
sometimes we see half of the moon lit
and sometimes we see the moon as a full
circle what causes this so here we have
the Sun the earth and the moon which
orbits around the earth these are not
drawn to scale at all that's why notice
that as the moon orbits around the earth
the side facing the Sun is the only side
that is illuminated imagine standing on
earth as the moon is in each of these
different points in its orbit around the
Earth
for example let's imagine standing on
earth looking towards the moon in the
direction of this arrow while the moon
is at its rightmost position here what
you see from Earth is from the arrows
point of view is the unlit side of the
moon what we know as a new moon now
let's imagine standing on earth looking
towards the moon in the direction of
this arrow while the moon is at its
bottom most position here what you see
from Earth is that half of the circle of
the moon is illuminated what we know
somewhat confusingly as a quarter moon
now let's imagine standing on earth
looking towards the moon in the
direction of this arrow while the moon
is at the leftmost position here what
you see from Earth from the arrows point
of view is the full illuminated face of
the moon known as a full moon cool so
now we know that the moon phase depends
on the relative positions of the moon
earth and Sun let's define some terms
the algorithm that we looked at uses two
different angles which are labeled in
the comments as the geocentric
elongation of a moon from the Sun and
the Cellino centric elongation of the
Earth's from the Sun what does that even
mean so the word geocentric means
centering the earth in other words it
means making calculations from the
Earth's point of view as if the Moon and
Sun revolved around it we know that this
was not actually true but it just refers
to using this reference point for
calculations the word Celino centric
centering the moon in other words it
means making calculations from the point
of view of the moon as if the Earth and
the Sun revolved around it again this is
not actually true but it just refers to
using this reference point for
calculations and let's use these points
of view to define some angles we might
use in our calculations we'll use the
angle between the moon and the Sun from
the Earth's point of view and we'll call
that Phi this is the geocentric
elongation of the moon from the Sun that
the code was referring to will also use
the angle between the Earth and the Sun
from the moon's point of view and we'll
call that theta theta is this Celino
centric elongation of the moon from the
Sun that the code was referring to the
code was using the variable name ink but
that isn't a Greek letter so let's call
it theta instead at this point it's
worth remembering that the Earth Moon
and Sun are three points in space so
they form a triangle what information in
this triangle do we know one of the
sides of the triangle has length equal
to the distance between the moon and the
earth this is a known distance and this
distance doesn't change as the moon
revolves around the earth and as the
Earth revolves around the Sun the
distance between the earth and the Sun
is also a known distance so we know the
length of that side of the triangle the
last side of the triangle will change in
length depending on the angles between
the Earth Moon and Sun do we know any of
those angles well by the geocentric
elongation of the moon from the Sun that
we were referring to the in other words
the angle that the Moon and Sun formed
from the point of view of the Earth is
something that we can observe given that
we are on earth it's not a constant but
since we can observe and measure it
let's count it is known with this
information we can calculate the last
side see with a law of cosines a quick
refresher on the law of cosines
it lets you calculate the length of an
unknown side of a triangle given its
opposite angle and two other sides
so given that we know the values for Phi
a and B see the distance between the
moon and the Sun is then the square root
of a squared plus B squared minus 2a B
cosine Phi and now that we know the
length of C we can calculate theta the
angle between the Earth and the Sun from
the moon's point of view and we can
calculate it using the law of sines so
quick refresher on the law of sines if
we know all the sides of the triangle
and one angle we can calculate the rest
of the angles via the law of sines the
law of sine states that the sine of an
angle divided by the length of the side
opposite that angle is equal to the sine
of any other angle in that triangle
divided by the length of the side
opposite that angle so in the case of
our triangle we can say that the sine of
Phi divided by C equals the sine of
theta divided by B and we can substitute
in the value of C that we calculated
from the law of cosines to get the
answer for the sine of theta and then
knowing the sine of theta theta is then
the arc sine of that value now that we
know how to calculate theta the angle
between the Earth and the Sun from the
point of view of the moon let's see how
it's related to the moon phase you might
notice that as the moon revolves around
the earth and changes phase theta
changes to can we find the equation that
describes the relationship between theta
and the fraction of the moon that's
visible from Earth to make it clearer
what part of the Moon is visible from
Earth at different points in its phase
we're adding a color key the white area
is a part illuminated by the Sun the
lavender area is the part not
illuminated by the Sun and finally the
dark purple area covers the side of the
Moon that faces away from Earth so the
white area that's left is what we can
see
the moon from the earths point of view
okay
so we'll try to figure out the equation
that describes the relationship between
theta and what fraction of the moon is
illuminated and visible from Earth let's
look at very specific example angles
when the angle between the Earth and Sun
from the point of the view of the moon
is 180 degrees the illumination percent
visible from Earth is zero when the
angle between the Earth and the Sun from
the point of the Moon point of view of
the moon is zero degrees the
illumination percent is a hundred a full
moon but those are very specific
examples how is theta related to the
fraction of the Moon that's visible for
any arbitrary value of theta so let's
zoom in to try to figure that out we do
know that the Sun lights exactly half of
the moon the right half and forms a
perpendicular side perpendicular with a
side of the moon that's lit so we can
mark that perpendicular that
perpendicular means that we can mark
this bottom lit area as having angle 90
minus theta the earth also forms a
perpendicular with a side of the moon
that is visible from Earth the side
opposite the dark purple side so we can
mark that as well this perpendicular
means that we can mark this upper lip
area as having angle 90 minus theta as
well so adding up all of the lit areas
of the moon the lit area of the moon
spans an angle of 100 minus theta or in
radians pi minus theta so to calculate
the illumination percent of fraction
from the illumination angle we can
naively make this calculation
using the angle illuminated by divided
by the total angle visible so the angle
illuminated is pi minus theta and the
total angle visible is 180 degrees or pi
but this doesn't accurately describe the
illuminated percent that we see because
the moon is a sphere and not a circle
and we need to take into account the
moon's curvature and how our eyes
perceive that curvature so instead we
want to calculate the length of the
projection of the curved surface of the
moon that are icy how do we calculate
that projection let's assume we know the
radius of a moon which we do when we
project our down we see that it's going
to be a portion of the distance that we
care about what is the other portion the
other portion of the distance is a leg
of this right triangle with hypotenuse R
and inner angle theta since the inner
angle forms a straight line with angle
PI minus theta and we know from trig
that the length of a side adjacent to an
angle in any right triangle is the
hypotenuse times the cosine of that
angle that's the definition of the
cosine right adjacent over hypotenuse so
now we know that the length of the top
side of the right triangle is R cosine
theta and we can project that down to
the distance that we care about adding
those two projected values together now
we know the length of the projection of
the illuminated portion of the moon as
visible from Earth to calculate the
fraction illuminated we divide by the
total projection which is the diameter
of the moon in other words to are when
we simplify the moon's radius cancels
itself out and we're left with cosine
theta plus 1 over 2 does that look
familiar
so K we did it from first principles we
calculated
the same equation as this library for
the fraction of the moon that's
illuminated so to recap the fraction of
a moon illuminated at any point in time
can be calculated with a cosine of theta
plus 1 over 2 where theta is the angle
between the Earth and the Sun from the
moon's point of view so I know that's a
lot of information to digest at once so
I put all of it together in an
interactive website for you to mess
around with on your own if you'd like
and it uses an interactive scrolling
library colds called scroll llama made
by the data visualization site the
pudding
currently it's only desktop friendly but
I'm working on making it mobile-friendly
soon and I can briefly demo it right now
[Music]
ok
as you scroll it'll kind of like have
some of the interactions from the
presentation
like it also we add all the pieces of
information that we know about this
triangle
or so we add all the angles that we
figure out in the zoomed in image of the
moon and theta yeah so it's a which eco
slash trig if you want to mess around
yeah so that's it thanks for listening
[Applause]